hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
I'm going to talk about the best snacks
per low blood sugar okay I used to have
low blood sugar and I used to have like
protein snacks and protein bars and
apples with peanut butter well don't
recommend that anymore because every
time you snack
you're gonna worsen the problem you're
gonna worsen the low blood sugar you're
gonna become a real hypoglycemic which
is almost a pre-diabetes situation so
continuing the snack always makes it
worse over time okay we're going to talk
about why so normal blood Sugar's 100
but it's usually between I'd say eighty
to ninety but you don't want it higher
than 100 okay and what that means is one
teaspoon of sugar diluted to your all of
your blood in your body like a gallon
and a half of blood roughly okay so
that's not that much sugar so what
happens when you eat a snack no matter
what you snack on it doesn't matter but
protein will do this as well you
actually elevate your sugars you're
bringing your sugar back up okay so the
sugar comes high and then that triggers
a hormone called insulin and the purpose
of insulin is to drive this sugar down
so you end up with a low blood sugar
situation so here you are eat a snack
wait a couple hours boom it's down again
you got to eat again it's high boom down
it keeps coming up and down up and down
up and down and this is what's happening
to a lot of people and it happens to me
as well and it just worsens the problem
because they really don't understand the
background what's behind the scene they
don't realize that they're continuing
the problem so you have to number one
realize that snacking worsens the
problem okay number two we have to
change what you eat at the meal so you
really want to do this where you have
three meals a day starting out no snacks
to do that and to stabilize your sugar
you need certain things one of the most
important things to help insulin be
stabilized and not go too high or too
low would be potassium potassium and
insulin work together okay so yes you
can take it as a supplement but I would
rather you get it from the food
and you guessed it vegetables give you
the most potassium so but here's the
thing you need between about seven to
ten cups of vegetable or even more salad
if you're going to do salad because
vegetables are a little bit more dense
every single day to get this potassium
requirement no one is doing that so
they're going to have a hard time fixing
this blood sugar situation so potassium
so you if you need a male meal the first
thing is you have your your vegetable
your salad okay so if I'm gonna do that
like I might do a kale shake well huge
salad I'll eat that first before
anything else okay that's number one so
I have vegetables I have a moderate
amount of protein for with each meal
okay that's like three to six ounces
don't want too much because that could
spike insulin as well just a moderate
amount but here's the thing that is
missing too if you do a lean piece of
meat or a protein shake with vegetables
you're gonna be starving because if you
already have a blood sugar problem it's
only gonna last like an hour to what you
need to add to make this transition
smooth you need to add fat okay like
nuts enough nuts or almond butter or nut
butters or avocado or brie cheese or
more olive in your salad dressing or or
butter to the point where you feel so
satisfied you can go from one meal to
the next comfortably okay so you have to
make those adjustments if you have too
much you might aggravate the gallbladder
and cause right shoulder pain and
headaches because the gallbladder has
nerves that run up there or too little
you're just going to be hungry now the
thing is that if someone has low blood
sugar to make this transition takes
about three weeks to two weeks sometimes
okay so until your body starts to get
used to it
but once you do it you will actually go
from one meal to next without much
hunger okay and so I put a video down
below of more details of how to do this
but even for kids you do not want kids
to snack between the meals don't get
them used to that because you're just
setting them up for a spike insulin
where they're constantly going to do
this and and the problem with this necks
is their so-called protein bars but they
always come with sugar
I mean there I looked at the protein
bars at the grocery store it's like all
over the place everything is hidden
sugars everywhere you go where does that
tell you it tells you that people are
not aware of the amount of sugar that's
in the food that's causing this blood
sugar thing because if you snack on a
Snickers bar or something sweet between
the meal or even an apple you're really
gonna make this thing a lot worse in
propel it into the future okay so a
protein would be the next best thing but
then just to cut it out completely that
would be the best thing to do and the
last thing I want to talk about is there
are certain things that will trigger
insulin okay sugar will do it excess
that protein will do it but the other
thing if you combine protein with sugar
you get an exaggerated spike of insulin
versus eating them separately so that
would be the protein bar with with the
added sugar to it and that's what
everyone's doing so again I'm just kind
of giving you some food for thought and
to give you enough information so you
can get out of this blood sugar trap
thanks for watching hey tell me what you
think about this video go ahead and
comment below and give me your feedback